[Música]
oi meu nome é oliver e hoje eu vim falar
sobre como podemos diminuir a
desnutrição e obesidade no mundo
você sabia que no brasil existem mais de
900 milhões de crianças desnutridas no
mundo
a desnutrição contribui para a morte de
três milhões de crianças por ano no
brasil 7,2 duas milhões de pessoas têm
falta de alimentos mas quem são essas
pessoas
populações indígenas região nordeste e
populações pobres das cidades
toda criança desnutrida tem um ou mais
problemas de nutrição esses problemas
são retardo do crescimento e maior risco
de obesidade e doenças crônicas na idade
adulta por exemplo é diabetes infarto e
alguns tipos de câncer
este é um mapa da organização mundial de
saúde que mostra os problemas de
nutrição das crianças menores de cinco
anos exceto estados unidos e europa
vamos ver alguns desses problemas é 155
milhões de crianças têm atrás no
crescimento 52 milhões têm e de crianças
têm baixo peso e 41 milhões têm excesso
de peso e ainda estamos falando das
crianças menores de cinco anos
ainda bem que no brasil a desnutrição
diminuiu bastante mas a obesidade
aumentou em 60% mais da metade das
pessoas está acima do peso e uma em cada
três crianças brasileiras também está
acima do peso o que se pode fazer
escolas podem da educação alimentar com
foco nas crianças adolescentes pessoas
entidades assistenciais podem doar e
distribuir alimentos saudáveis às
pessoas carentes
governo e empresas podem incentivar a
produção de alimentos saudáveis mais
baratos e diminuir a propaganda de
alimentos nocivos
o que nós crianças podemos fazer na
família com os amigos e na escola
podemos doar alimentos saudáveis e as
pessoas carentes alimentos saudáveis e
obviamente e incentivar e motivar as
pessoas para ter uma alimentação mais
saudável
além disso podemos evitar alimentos
ultra processados que são alimentos com
substâncias químicas sal e açúcar
disfarçados e normalmente eles venham
latinhas sacos e preferir os alimentos
naturais
vamos começar já muito obrigado
[Aplausos]